it doesn't okay
okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the subcommittee for
uh HBA 354
um and just so everybody's aware where
we're going there are a number of
reasons why HP 354 was retained one yes
it's a charter school Bill where School
building Aid would be directed towards
the construction and eligibility of this
those schools to receive State dollars
but two we are also very very concerned
after we have gone through the process
of other bills this year dealing with
school building Aid when we're seeing
there's some level of dissatisfaction in
regard to the funding formula for school
building Aid within this state and
within this legislature and by that I
mean there was a a draft Amendment
proposed by a legislator
to fund School building Aid based upon
per capita amount each year
and that Drew a number of issues and
concerns the per capita you know costs
like that one would take some school
districts based upon how many years do
we talk about Amy about 90 to 100 years
before they'd have enough money for a
Schoolhouse but two it also provided
money to school districts like Albany
that don't have schools and there would
be no need for school construction
dollars so there are a lot of issues
there and so we're gonna have to tackle
both of these issues and while we're
talking about the the bill itself we
also then are going to be going Way
Beyond in terms of that whole chapter of
law in terms with school building Aid
and um as you know there is a limited
number of schools which receive Charter
building Aid each year
and of course it's capped also at up to
50 million bucks uh
the the and we'll get into it that's
obviously not covering what our needs
are in the state right now
and so with that
um many districts that see themselves
way down that list they're saying I'm
never going to see school building a
dollars so why should I vote for this
bill
and so or any bill on that see it's
going to be so delayed that it's not
going to ever really you know be
productive for my particular community
so with that I'd like to get on with it
today we have uh representative Mooney's
here and she is the prime sponsor of
354. we also have Amy Clark from the
Department of Education which when I
talked with Amy she was willing to give
us an overview of where we are with
school building Aid and on some ideas
too as Maybe
Concepts that we should be thinking
about and where we're going and and
where we might go with a formula which
um
there there are a lot of issues and
we'll see some of those addressed today
so
um I'm gonna start off for about five or
ten minutes Maureen can you give a brief
overview of your bill just for a short
time and then we're going to get into uh
the doe and and then get on to our
discussion
there are no need for pink cards today
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is representative Maureen Mooney
I represent the town of
Merrimack that's Hillsborough County
District 12. first of all I want to
thank you for taking the time to
thoroughly discuss and review this bill
I'm the prime sponsor on House Bill 354.
I'll keep my comments brief but I do
want to do three things I'm going to
give you a long-term history a
short-term history and then review what
the bill does in two parts
so let's start with the long term
last term
I introduced a very similar Bill to this
one and it was to allow public charter
schools to apply apply in the process
for school building Aid doesn't mean get
it it means apply
there were several questions with that
bill last term with regards to who owns
the building and what would happen so on
so forth so I took that and worked with
others to craft language which brings me
to the short term I introduced then
House Bill 354 which incorporates
answers to questions of who owns the
building and this being limited to only
those charter schools that own their own
buildings
now House Bill 354 was retained in this
committee this past year
but also I'll have you know this
in-house Finance I introduced this exact
Bill word for word as an amendment to
house bill 2.
house finance committee
adopted this exact language to House
Bill 2 with a vote of 25 to zero
House Bill 2 then went from house
finance to the floor of the house and as
you know it passed through the floor of
the house on a Voice vote
the language then
was then removed in Senate finance
committee why I don't know
House Bill 2 then adopted as we know
just last Thursday and this has been
excluded
so that then leads me to the content of
this bill
it does in my opinion
two things
first and I'd like to give a handout if
I could to clarify this point
it clears up a very obvious
contradiction currently in New Hampshire
law
I've created this handout
currently an RSA 194 hyphen B colon 11
Roman
7.
very clear
no school building Aid shall be awarded
to public charter schools
clear
then in 198 colon 15 hyphen B
the amount of the grant to any chartered
Public School established in accordance
with RSA 194 B3 shall be 30 percent of
the eligible cost of construction
I go back to a bill that was introduced
in house finance this past year and it
was to fund a position at the Department
of Education for an attorney to go
through the education statute
specifically and recodify them and find
contradictions
when the Department of Education
introduced that bill to house finance
they used this
as the example for why the position was
needed and why there are discrepancies
and controversies and contradictions and
cleanups needed in the education
statutes
this Bell House Bill 354 would clean it
up
you would remove where it says Charter
Schools cannot receive building Aid it
Part B of what this bill does again I go
back to
it's simply allows
public chartered schools in New
Hampshire that own their own buildings
to apply and go through the process like
any other Public School in New Hampshire
for school building Aid
so that would require review by the
Department of Education you know warrant
articles the whole nine yards there
which can be articulated best by Amy
Clark and those from the Department of
Ed that are here
simply would allow public charter
schools again that own their own
buildings to apply whether or not they
get it that's up to the process this
bill would allow them to apply
so with that Mr chairman I've given you
the history of the bill from last term
the most recent history of the bill
including it coming out of Finance 25 to
nothing and being attached to the house
version of House Bill 2 only to be
scraped by the Senate and then here we
are today and what the bill would do I
do have uh people here from the
Department of Education and from the
charter school community that would also
like to speak I'm sure and answer
questions if you have them and with that
I will conclude my testimony and thank
you again all of you for your time thank
you very much
is there a need for any further
information from
uh representative Mooney
nuts thank you
so what I'd like to do then now is that
would 354 we know that this was taken
out of hb2 so we're right now where we
were at the beginning of this year
without building Aid going to the
charter schools
um
now there's also the issue that we had
with several other bills dealing with
that we had requested funding uh that
would support some of the needs for
public schools and we again are are been
limited uh there too as well so what I'd
like to do is take a moment right now uh
and invite Amy Clark up to try and and
walk us through a little bit of
information but go ahead and set up Amy
um I want to also explain what is in
your pack of the materials that you've
received here
um you know of course a copy of 354.
that should be right the first on the on
the list there
then there was this a sheet which
identified hb2 building 8 considerations
and and I'm going to just allude this
very quickly here on the bottom of that
sheet this looks like there's a table up
there I don't want you looking at the
table itself I want to look at the the
bottom of that sheet and going on to the
next sheet
um there's issues needing resolution
here with the current
formula and that which was proposed by
the representative do it on a per pupil
basis
one of the things that this committee's
got to resolve here is there a way to
fund smaller projects alongside the
larger ones we have a number of projects
that come in which are asking for
much lesser money than the big uh 80
million dollar projects or the 20
million dollar projects these might be
projects three million dollars or less
to renovate a Schoolhouse primarily a a
lot of these smaller k through eight
districts
then we also have questions which are on
the our considerations on the second
side how do Charters fit into the
process we just heard this and uh we
have to be looking at you know are we
going to be funding at 30 we fund from
30 to 60 percent based upon medium
income families and property valuations
what about emergency projects
there's another issue which we have to
be cognizant of should billing Aid pay
for Career Technical education space
that's used within a high school
situation
through security and safety issues need
to rise to the top
of our formula and we do have the
infrastructure fund but that's uh not
addressing some of the issues that would
come under play here with some of the
other safety type issues within the
buildings access like you know do you
have access to the second floor of your
building Believe It or Not we've had
within just the last year or so one
building a project went out to just
afford a person in a wheelchair to get
into the school
more or less to the second floor of the
school in Romney to get up to where his
or her student was receiving an
education
um going on down we did look at this uh
should charitable trust be quests gifts
insurance policies be subtracted from
their state grant that was an issue that
was brought up by
representative cascaden here and uh uh
those folks from in the superintendent
Taylor
in regard to new construction offset
State share a building Grant by sale of
any assets building property from
previous facilities should the sale the
property offset what they get from the
grant
consideration or the sale of the lease
studying methods of ensuring long-term
sustaining sustainability funding for
school buildings and identify sources of
such funds
sustainability is very important but
even more so where do these funds come
from we have tried for years to have
more than 50 million dollars per year
allocated to schools you can put in
bills say no less than 50 million every
time we've done that we've met a brick
wall
already going on down should State share
of Grant be flat funded
um consider Community wealth these but
flat funded but we also consider some
variables like Community wealth income
levels levels of grades in the school of
geographic location demographics of the
school itself should 80 be provided
immediately immediately upon you know in
the formula right now you get a grant 80
percent of the state share comes to you
right out of the blocks uh it used not
to be like that we put it at 80 percent
so that the we could reduce the interest
costs of the local school district
they used to get it incrementally over
the period duration of that loan
um
uh and or should it be reduced so it's
spread over the life of the bond uh if
you did that you could probably fund a
few more projects each year but then you
run the risk of going closer to a tail
again more debt which we had 540 million
dollars debt when I first came on board
here in school building eight alone
um assess eligibility criteria based
upon need and we want to look at other
state funding models we had our
researcher back to the table there I did
briefly one day and she came in and
presented several other types of plans
which were going in the state of
Kentucky in the state of Virginia we we
want to look at that too and lastly
what is the state condition of our
buildings right now we've never been
able other than the surveys put out by
Doe to ascertain what you think you have
there behind that wall whether you think
there's asbestos there or not
um and that custodian might say yeah
well we got it there may not be anything
there uh so we we need to really
ascertain what is out there as far as
the the buildings in terms of the same
assessment for every school house in
this state so we have some consistent
criteria so we can start projecting uh
in the cost for our 10-year plan which
we've thought so hard to do so that's
where we are with some of the issues
which we have to attack and and try to
address here right now before we talk to
Amy yes yeah I think there's another
issue that uh Beyond this list and that
is there is didn't we retain a bill that
dealt with the dissolution of charter
schools and how that should be done it
would seem to me that that also is a is
a related issue here
because if charter schools are in fact
going to begin getting money and they
should ultimately that and put that into
a building
and ultimately
dissolve as we have I think we've had
like five or six of our charter schools
have uh dissolved what is a relationship
of the money that goes into that Charter
School from the states as far as
building goes
what happens to that who's responsible
for it where's the money come from
where's the asset and the um the growth
of that asset what happens to it so that
I think Rick that's a that's a related
issue here yes definitely and and the
charter schools uh when we look at
building a for the charter schools all
this comes from the play and as we've
read parts of the of the law if a
charter school does dissolve
then who ends up having to pay that
burden for the debt that that District
may have been in the district and also
that and also the value of that asset so
so yeah so there's a lot to this and so
that we're gonna have to really engage
and work hard on this from the charter
school perspective and from the
perspective of Aid to all public schools
and with that I'm going to hand it off
to you Amy if you can give us a a brief
background uh of where we are on all
this it'd be appreciated sure uh so I
know I've met all of you several times
at this point but again my name is Amy
Clark and I work for the Department of
Education in the Bureau of school
facilities uh building Aid falls under
my Bureau as well uh and so I um I'm
happy to go over the summary that's in
your packet if you feel that it's
helpful
um and kind of just give you a
step one through building aid but I also
don't wanna
if you all feel like you're experts and
you're good to go but I also know you
hear from a lot of Department of
Education so I'm happy to do that
overview again would that be helpful
yeah yeah I think it would be you know
you can do a shorter version to hit on
is the 30 to the 60 and and some of the
criteria you're using in awarding these
grants out sure um and I believe that's
in your packet so
um representative Ladd just went over
that list I think the next is
um House Bill two looks like there's
some research and then it gets to this
page uh which is just the cover sheet so
if you get to that page that's where I'm
going to kind of start that's a copy of
um the summary that I typically give uh
and so the following page so it's just
like what's in this packet that's a
table of contents page with my contact
information if you ever need me
um so I'm gonna really spend time on
this page mine is color copied I don't
think yours is but
um it has a table at the bottom uh so
essentially uh building Aid RSA 195 15
we have rules that support it um under
Ed 321 and the basics really are
building Aid is just the state portion
of a large construction project what
it's not it's not
um you already mentioned CT no it's no
we don't well
it's separate from the CTE funding
program which a lot of people know know
about it is not Public School
infrastructure fund money so when you
hear about security grants and things
like that that's not also not building
Aid there's another portion
um lease Aid falls under 198.15 and
that's lease grants to charter schools
for to help pay for the lease payments
that's under RSA 19815 but that is also
not building Aid building Aid is really
for large construction projects
representative Mooney mentioned that
there is in building Aid right now
charter schools are
eligible through 198.15 but are
prohibited through 194 B from applying
so
um just to Echo what she said that
um to be honest when I started I was
only in charge of 198 15 rules and uh
charter school called me within the
first year and I was like yeah fill out
an application so
um so um so it was news to me a little
later on that they were not eligible I
apologized and we didn't end up getting
any money anyway so
um
through building Aid ranges the building
Aid rate for the state's portion of this
large construction project is 30 to 60
percent it's not a linear formula
meaning the average isn't between those
numbers it's heavily weighted to the 38
to the 30 percent end the average rate
for schools is 38 percent uh in
um using that formula
uh and as you can imagine more affluent
communities are at the 30 percent range
less affluent are at the 60 percent
range there's not a ton of schools at
that 60 percent uh the funding source is
the education trust fund and Remains the
education trust fund didn't have to make
an edit there
um the history of building Aid the quick
history of building Aid is it has been
around since the 40s the 1940s and has
been given reliably to all construction
projects for public schools all the way
up through 2009 uh so I just want to say
that one more time because I think it's
important to remember that at one time
the state paid for a portion 30 to 60
percent the formula has changed over the
years but it's been 30 to 60 percent of
any public school construction project
even things that are now not eligible
were eligible prior to 2009 uh what was
eligible were SAU offices that's no
longer eligible what was eligible would
be if a school wanted to replace all
their windows or do a roof replacement
that was eligible and those are no
longer eligible so just keep in mind
that that's the kind of the history that
it's been there
the law changed in 20 so essentially
what happened I'm going to go down to
this table in in the green here uh or
you don't have the color copy sorry the
the table below
um essentially from 1946 to 2009 that
63-year period money was appropriated to
meet demand so the application
applications would come to the
department the department would report
to the legislature how much money was
being asked for and then that money was
appropriated a few times it was a
shortfall
and we would short all the schools the
same rate so maybe the state was short
five percent and we would um cut those
Awards across the board by five percent
um a few years there were shortfalls but
not many that I that I'm aware of
um from 2010 to 2019 so the following
10-year period there was a two-year
moratorium that was put in place so a
two-year moratorium started in 2010 and
schools what I think just to kind of
think about as a person from a school
what they thought was two years
because I think this is really important
they thought two years it's a temporary
moratorium will come out of moratorium
who is going to build during that two
two years when they know the grant
program is going to be opened up in two
years later when they could get state
aid so that two years I can pretty much
assure you there was no construction
going on two years later the moratorium
was again added for another two years so
schools have been in this oh no just
wait two more years it's not like
schools knew that there was a 10-year
moratorium so I think maybe around year
eight people are kind of having a hint
that maybe building Aid was struggling a
little bit and I think a few schools
went on to build without state aid
um we know Oyster River just built a
beautiful school
um there's some a few others out there
that built schools without state aid but
during that 10-year period not a lot of
schools built with State AIDS certainly
not struggling communities
um built during that time
um there was one project that was funded
through
um House Bill 2 amended a lifted the
moratorium to allow this one project to
be funded um that was Hinsdale they had
some kind of emergency situation it was
a 3.6 million dollar project the state
aid portion was 2.2 million
um so other than that one project there
was a 10 years without building Aid uh
and then for the first time the budget
from 20 to 21 that that biennium budget
was the first time it was lifted
um building the moratorium disappeared
was removed from House Bill 2 for the
first time in 10 years and
um schools applied
thought we had a list of five schools
they were ranked
um those schools were trying to get
building Aid they were requesting 45
million dollars or their their projects
totaled 45 million dollars they were
requesting 17 million in state aid for
that biennium three of those projects
were funded
um the funding amount there is is there
as well 40 million dollars was fun uh 40
million dollars per year
um
hmm
plus that 8.6 million uh I have to look
to see more Rusty apparently the total
projects for that was 8.6 million we'll
see on a chart in in on the next page
um so in that
um keep in mind that five projects a lot
of people would have asked why did only
five schools apply when you had this
10-year moratorium why didn't you have
more schools apply well you have to
apply for building Aid a year ahead of
time and we were in a moratorium and I'm
pretty sure most of the schools that
applied really were very surprised that
they got building Aid and so you can see
building Aid was lifted and in 2022 and
2023 that biennium we had 12 schools
apply now what's interesting is you have
to apply keep in mind fiscal 22 actually
starts in 2021 right July 1st of 2021
you have to apply a year in advance so
now we're talking about July of 2020 so
now we're deep in a pandemic so now the
laboratorium has been lifted but we have
schools applying during the moratorium I
mean during the pandemic so again 12
schools did apply
we had in January
so January of 2020
pre-pandemic sort of January 2020
there's part of the law requires
um you to notify the Department of
Education if you're going to apply it's
called the letter of intent we had 50
schools in January of 2020 tell us that
they were going to apply for building
Aid by the time the application process
rolled around which was July of 2020
much much different schools were doing
lots of things other than applying for
building Aid and 12 schools put in
applications so just again thinking
about this list isn't necessarily a
perfect snapshot of who would be
applying for building Aid and then this
past more uh this passed by any well
this
biennium coming we had 17 schools apply
and they applied last year they were
ranked and we just realized that of
those 17 schools the budget includes
enough to fund three of them
um
I put TBD there but I guess we will soon
have a signature and no so
um but it looks like three schools will
receive funding through that process
and the only other thing I'll mention I
think that's important to note is that
um in 2023 in the middle of the
moratorium because the moratorium starts
in 2010. in 2013 the law drastically
changes it says there's a big revision
of the law and it said we're no longer
going to fund projects on demand well on
demand meaning we're no longer going to
fund all the projects instead we're
going to make it a competitive process
we're going to Cap building Aid at 50
million dollars
um
um we were also at that time in 2010
spending about 60 million dollars a year
in building Aid so at that time there
was a cap put on a 50 million dollars in
building Aid and um what happens when
you have a cap is it now becomes a
competitive process and so now in order
to figure out who gets that money
there's a whole ranking process that's
in involved and you mentioned some of
those the security
um unsafe conditions either structural
issues mechanical issues Plumbing issues
educational space suitability issues
overcrowding
consolidation all of those things that
you now get points for
which
um
leads to one of the biggest problems of
that ranking is that you get all these
points for really big projects right so
if you wanted to put in let's say a
security vestibule or if you wanted to
add an addition for to expand a program
those smaller projects are hard to get
building aid for because you're not
checking all of those boxes like a brand
new school would or if you're
consolidating schools those projects
also score really high as well
um not that those aren't worthy projects
but that is kind of what flushes out is
all those new schools or consolidation
projects float to the top and some of
the smaller projects don't
uh and the next page is really just the
rates if you were thinking about like
who what rates does my um
areas have my towns have those are the
rates right there the billing Aid rates
and then
um this graph especially because if
you're thinking about funding it
differently one of the
um items on your list was whether you
want to think about continuing that 80
percent model or paying over the tail I
didn't really talk about that much but
prior to 2013 if you recall I said the
law changed drastically prior to 2013
the state paid on the term of the bond
so if you got a 10 million dollar award
and you were a 20-year Bond you would
get a half a million dollars every year
for 20 years
in 2013 that changed you already
mentioned it and now you get the award
up front to get 80 percent of your award
prior to construction 20 upon completion
so we're done paying within two to three
years or however long it takes for the
project so when you hear the word tale
this is what they're talking about I
suppose it does look like a tail
um this tale is the obligated payments
on those Bond payments we were making
prior to 2000 for projects prior to 2013
which really are projects prior to 2010
since we didn't fund any anything from
2010 to 2013.
um you can see it goes all the way out
to 2041 that's actually a 30-year bond
that didn't start until 2011 those are a
couple of the final schools that were
applied in 2009 and by the time they got
their financing so that's where those
2041 so in 2041 the tale will be gone
unless the Law changes and adds a new
tail so
um
so with that I feel like that's a quick
summary if there's anything else you
want me to hit specifically on the
summary piece of things
okay are there any questions yes or need
from further information yes uh looking
at the chart on your summary page I'm
interested
uh 20 20 22 23. we said this there were
12 applications for new projects
and two are funded is that correct two
were funded that's correct now is that
is that two that were funded did that
take up the available funding that was
in the budget at that time it it did if
you actually um if you look on that
graph as well
um
that was 22.23
um what interestingly if you if so if
you look on this graph of 22 and 23 ish
those solid bars are the tail obligated
payments
um the state also took out a bond in
2010 to meet a shortfall that they had
so that there's the bond payment as well
on there but the dashed lines are the
new project payments and so in 22 and 23
let me actually was that
so 22 and 23
um the state actually stacked the
appropriation from you can see in 2023
no money so this current year we were
given no money for building Aid instead
they over paid extra in 2022 so that 30
million went to those two projects and
actually one project was fully funded
and the second project was
uh the second project I'm going to guess
we shorted them about seven million
dollars from there so it didn't pay for
and so that meant that the State Board
makes these decisions they make this
allocation correct uh no the um the
legislature does we make that decision
so so the decision to fund just to
uh at the rate that you just indicated
was made rather than
funding smaller amounts to more
applications is that correct
um yes and no the the all the projects
those 12 projects that come in the law
requires that this the Department of
Education the state board of education
rank those projects if the small
projects ranked High because they scored
lots of points they just get picked off
from the top of the list
um the first rank project actually
wasn't selected because they didn't pass
their warrant article
um so the the next project Pastor Warren
article so we've gave funding to them
um answer your question yeah until we
run out of money so we picked a project
off paid for it who else passed their
warrant article yep you did offered the
money and then the second project we
offered to actually wanted more but we
only had whatever remaining we had for
them yeah
so maybe you can explain this to the
group so a
a number of schools obviously did not
receive funding
um this year
or in the previous go around as well
beyond the two or the three now if
you're one that didn't receive for
example let's take Concord this year so
their project for the state cost was
roughly what run as I think around
recall 70 million dollars thereabouts
and that would just kind of wipe out our
entire account for funding that school
in its entirety but if a school doesn't
receive in a given year are they
automatically put on the list at the top
or they have to compete against with all
those other projects were coming in and
they're reprioritized how's it work okay
so these questions are going to get a
little complicated because House Bill
452 was signed into law last month so
the process is now a little different
than the folks that are play that have
that on the list right now
um and so
um the department still needs to make
some rules on that and literally just
pass maybe three weeks ago
um but the the law used to read I'll try
to so what it used to say
um last month was that if you didn't get
funding if you passed your warrant
article but the states didn't have money
you could stay on the list for the next
biennium
but the problem with that is you know
you're not going to get money if you're
project number 11. so why would you even
ask your voters to for a vote you're
just wasting time so so House Bill 452
corrects that
um I hope that it will correct it anyway
I have to get down on the nitty-gritty
to it but
um and some of that will come with
rulemaking but the new process will be
that you get to stay on the list
regardless of the vote even if you had a
failed vote you get to stay on the list
for so many years
um three years four years I think that
that's going to be determined by
rulemaking
I thought 452 they could get bumped if
there's a project that came in with uh
uh some of those needs such as safety
Etc yes absolutely you are correct so if
you are a project there is one way you
can get bumped and is if you apply and
you have higher life safety points you
have to score more than half of the
points and you have to have more points
than people that are above you that were
on the list prior then you can jump
through jump to the top of the ranking
so now this new process kind of creates
this waiting line and it'll be
interesting to see how long that line
gets represent cascad and then represent
already
yes that's a good question so this is
the fiscal 24 and 25. this is our list
for this year you know how I said they
have to apply a year ahead of time these
are the schools that applied for this
coming but budget
um and the budget has passed with enough
funds not that they'll get funding but
enough funds to cover the top three
projects we know Rochester is prepared
to take funds and we know Monadnock has
passed their Warren article Colebrook
failed but they'll get one other
opportunity to do so because it's a
biennium list
um and if they pass next year then that
correct correct yep and that would be
the case for everybody is this a
biennium list so next year the list
doesn't change nobody adds to it nobody
can apply for building Aid um it's
different with the new law so the next
two years the the list will have the
um
so um now 9 10 and 11 and I apologize if
that was your original question uh okay
um not page 9 10 and 11. those are our
those obligated payments those are our
projects that we're still paying on that
were constructed prior to 2010.
um those are are what we call our tail
payments
and so every year that list gets shorter
and shorter because we pay on the term
of the bond so every year a handful of
those fall off because that they made
their last Bond payment and that's what
allows that 50 million to grow so in in
theory in 2013 the theory was that you
keep that you'd pay off that tail once
it's paid off you'll have a consistent
50 million
um per year to spend not 50 million is a
lot different than it was in 2009 than
it is now but that was the
projects
then they still apply for a new project
two years in the past I know there's
still in somewhere in the field house
but should we start the process all over
again or if they can even move forward
with
it
yeah so everybody that's not on the list
of 17 this 24-25 list that's all of the
people that are on the list right now
anybody who know who's not will need to
apply for building Aid if they're
interested there's no other list however
this list of payments that doesn't
preclude people from applying for
building a just because Littleton or any
other District got building Aid they can
still apply for another school or for
you know another project but what
building Aid does it's um
uh it's also important to remember that
everybody is playing by the same set of
rules so even even conquered I know
people don't always want to think so but
when they when they're requesting uh
realize this isn't your question but
when they're requesting 76 million that
doesn't mean that they're eligible for
20 for I mean I'm sorry if they're
requesting 76 million it's important to
remember that that doesn't mean that
they're eligible for 76 million they are
eligible per square footage per student
cost per square foot the same as any
other project
um so with that said that there is a
caveat in building Aid is that you can't
we are not going to pay for space that
was just touched and paid for with
building Aid in the past 40 years I
think the rule actually says 35 years so
the thought was they could apply in 35
years by the time they're actually
constructing it would be 40 years so
essentially the goal is to not be paying
for a space that received building Aid
in the last 40 years so anybody on this
list for a very specific project
I happen to be at the top of the list
Amherst they did a renovation for these
these particular spaces we have on
record you don't see it here but we have
on record on our end how much square
footage that those schools worked on
those areas are prohibited from
receiving building Aid again for 40
years and if they wanted to
take those schools and
if they wanted to take those spaces and
move to a brand new building we would
allow we would allow them to do that but
we would deem all of those Square
footages ineligible for Billy Eid their
spaces would essentially be prorated
so they could still move we just
wouldn't pay for those spaces for the
new construction piece of it with the
thought that the states
the buildings that they're building
should be lasting at least 40 years
if a school was on the initial eligible
list didn't make it and it's still there
um
and they were ranks I think number eight
and then in the new process the new 400
legislation coming in
we had to replay again
where they carry over the state number
eight I guess I guess my question is
does the ranking drop because new uh
School applications they're ranked
higher
but there were eight before and I
dropped to 18th or do they still stay at
eight something else goes below them
they now still stay at eight
unless a school a new school applies and
they have scored more than half the life
safety points and they have more life
safety points than the people on the
list than they can jump so you have to
score a lot of
um life safety uh they're actually
called unsafe condition unsafe condition
points you have to score more than half
of them and if you score more than half
of them that you're unsafe and you can
jump number eight
um all the way to somebody else who
doesn't have as many life safety points
as you do or unsafe condition points
so taking that one point then that the
life safety uh points as you scale your
applications that would be the most
critical party upgrade correct I think
um of a fou that's a thousand points
they can score and I think the unsafe
know how to score your application
and in the just for a clarifying
question in the or just to clarify in
the case of Littleton Littleton applied
for an intent to fund but they didn't
file an actual application so they were
never ranked and that was similar with
many people who applied during that time
and and I know that they are getting
ready to apply again is that for their
Elementary School the two-story building
yeah okay yeah and and it is also
important like that's really important
that when you're thinking about a new
process that building us new school is a
long process it's not something that you
can just all of a sudden be like we need
to you know there's a lot of vetting
what the community wants it's a really
long process
when you talk about uh you corrected me
once when we were doing the 452 or you
know there and I was using the wrong
figure for for square feet per pupil I
was using just solely the classroom
figure I think that's around 300 per
pupil roughly
um so what is it for the entire facility
with everything else yeah it's about
150. it's it varies but it varies high
school elementary big school little
school but in general it's about 150
square feet per student for the entire
facility or is on top of the classroom
space now for the entire facility 150
square feet yeah you could take the
enrollment of any school multiply it by
150 square feet per student and you
would get their approximate size now
you would get the approximate size that
would be eligible for building Aid
um okay more so schools are probably
building a closer to 180 square feet per
student some schools are even up to 200
square feet per student
special education spaces drive that some
schools have really strong let's just
say music programs and so they have an
orchestra room and a violin room those
those spaces aren't those are above and
beyond awesome that they have those
spaces they're just not qualify for
those minimums special education spaces
are certainly something that this
committee might want to or at least for
rule making anyway we'll be taking a
look at I guess it's actually outside
the law but
um is those special education spaces
what those needs are in schools
sorry I'm a little bit confused you're
saying I had on this sheet right here
144 square feet
that's about right yeah uh but what is
the cost of that square foot yeah that
cost of that square footage is a right
now we're running about about
550 a square foot so I think so we also
Cap Construction costs and that's where
I think the difference was between your
numbers and mine so construction costs
are capped um we we track the costs that
um a public school project uses or um
submits receipts for and then we cap
those based on a National Standard index
to New Hampshire even indexed down to
the county
um and so those are about construction
we're talking about um envelope actual
construction of the building
um that's about varies but about 220
dollars a square foot and that doesn't
include engineering fees architect fees
site development Furniture fixtures
equipment things like that I mean it
doesn't include uh
an elevator if you had an elevator in
your building so things like that
correct now it's eligible for building
Aid which is what that 550 dollars per
square foot is we just have a cap very
specific on construction costs
um but there are caps on land too it's
just it's done per acre
um and at the rate the market value rate
it's hard to do that Manchester's
property is much different than and you
can't really cap it by County so it's
really what the market value is and then
we allow so many acres per per student
you can it is eligible for building Aid
correct yeah are these national
standards you're talking about correct
um National Construction standards uh
it's an industry-wide the the manuals
that they put out you can look them up
for a hospital you can look them up by
gas stations elementary school middle
school high school
um it's RS means it's a national
standard
yes representative represent Luna
if I may focus on Charter Schools sure
yeah you may not be able to answer this
and I have um towel bear is here too
he's a charter school administrator from
the Department of Education let me give
charter schools
with a grant of let's say a million
dollars from the federal government
there's some private money that comes in
to help start that school
they want to they want to purchase a
bill
so the combination of
the startup fees private fees and let's
say in this instance even some State
money
they purchase a building they renovate
the building
and they get it ready for school they
take on a mortgage
and at the end of the third year let's
say
there's still the mortgage on the
building they've got Assets in the
building Etc and the charter school
decides it goes on the end of our
our charging
[Music]
what happens to the assets
of that charter school where does it go
I'm assuming I'm assuming the charter
schools are 501c3
but there's some legal issues here
but the question would be particulars
begin to look at uh State contributions
as well as Federal competitions you're
creating this asset now we've got a
building here the school's now going to
be gone
what happens to that asset who's
responsible for the uh mortgage of it
that's still outstanding as well as the
assets that have been put in from the
federal government and the state
government is issues what happens to
that asset at that point
yeah I'll let tile come on up and then I
guess I'll just point out from the
building Aid perspective
um you know I can talk a little bit more
about
um that part of it but on building Aid
does have a requirement a penalty it
requires the school payback the full
amount of the award if they change uses
within in 20 years I realize your
question is more about how you get that
that money so there is a requirement for
schools public schools anybody who
applies for billing Aid receives billing
Aid to pay it back if they change uses
within the 20-year period Then I do
believe representative Mooney's um Bill
did have some proposal for that
if there's Federal moneys involved in
that how does that I understand the
state I mean reimbursement yeah I was a
federal money yep so um for again for
all our applications what we do is when
they um fill out their
um their application there's a couple
application processes that they go
through they make estimates
um during the initial period but then in
the final when they're getting ready to
get that last 20 percent of their award
or their final payment they have to
submit a full statement of all of their
um Grant all of their statements and on
that we subtract out any kind of federal
funding that they receive so building
Aid is paid on the the so if you think
about the project total and then we
subtract out the federal portion that
they get and pay state aid based on the
remaining portion we we change that
remember we were the the grant if for
example it was which generated that
concern from superintendent Taylor the
state and grant money
is
taken out they can use the gift money
but they can use the for their local
match so if you're thinking about the
state match and then the local match
um federal dollars you cannot use for
your local match you can now with a
passage of 452 use gifts a donations for
your local match but federal dollars you
cannot so it comes off the top we don't
they can't use it for their local share
portion of it
Dave did you have
okay
good afternoon towel bear with the
charter school office and hopefully I
will not confuse this issue any more
than it appears it might be
um it's a complicated answer
um because it really depends on where
the funds come from specific to the
charter school so if you've got
restricted uh donations to a charter
school if it if it dissolves then those
restrictions would come into play if
they're federal funds that were used in
the operation of that charter school
then you're going to be dealing with
federal guidelines and then depending on
the amounts of those funds or items or
assets
um it kind of drives it in a different
direction than into the state funds
that's a whole a whole nother kettle of
fish so I do think it's a it's a more
complicated issue than just simply
they're dissolving what happens and then
lastly I would add I would assume with
the if you have a bank they're the lien
holder on the property
um I would assume that the bank would be
the owner of that property and would
have to pay pending I I'd be shocked if
they would do some kind of first I
forget the legal term but where
I used to be in Mortgage Banking and you
didn't you were always the first lien
holder and if the loan ever failed we
always got our money back first so I
don't know how that works at the at
least here in New Hampshire I just know
back home that was kind of how we
operated
by what you're saying there needs to be
some clarification on how that's going
to be handled I I do think there should
be some color clarification the other
and just along the same lines just
pointing out that the draft Bill also
included a different payment schedule
again the bill well it's you guys are
talking about it today so obviously
that's why it's here but the the payment
in the bill talks about breaking up
payments not giving it all up front and
then paying upon completion instead it's
giving 20 of it every year for five
years I think that was another way to
make sure that the state held on to some
of those that money under that same
concern
can I get something I just would also
add something for consideration
um we're not talking about school
buildings
um the size of Traditional School
buildings many of these Charter Schools
could be you know 300 to half million I
if we have charter schools with three to
five million dollar buildings that's
kind of a rare exception most of their
buildings are fairly small
it's a charter conversion school work
into this if I'm a public school
district I say oh I'm going to become a
charter conversion School my school
board is still there it's owned by the
municipality
how's that work in conjunction with this
law
um so under building Aid you can the
district the school district can just
apply for building Aid because they're
the owners if I if I'm understanding
your question right that the school
district can still apply for building
aid for those
um District spaces
so the school board no longer has a
rigor Public School it has a public
charter conversion School
I guess I'm not the school board has a
district approved Charter which it's a
separate process that they would
essentially get their Charter approved
through their local district and their
Town process once that's completed then
the state does the final side off but
yeah it would it would be a separate
process
and I'd have to re-look at 194b but I
believe the pro so again building Aid is
set up to allow charter schools to apply
for Aid it's 194b in the charter school
law that prevents them from applying but
I do believe 195 194b allows District
conversion schools to apply for building
Aid we just do we have any of those no
you don't we don't so we've always just
said oh they're not eligible because
there's none available but if it was
that type of charter school then they
would they would still they would be
able to apply for building Aid under the
current law
yes represent cordelli and then
representative Luna thank you thank you
Mr bear um go ahead I'm sorry no it's
okay
I think
um maybe last term the application
process for a charter school was revised
so that it had to include a dissolution
plan if they owned their own building is
is part one is that correct
partially all of them have to include a
dissolution plan regardless of building
ownership
and
follow up if yes go ahead um I think in
this bill there is a provision so that
if a building is improved or constructed
During the period
um that they have to have that plan in
place but it should already be there as
part of their application process that
is that correct
correct
represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair
um going back to um to representative
miler's question I think also what
representative cordelli
was also you know uh referencing to I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about how that how the clawback
um uh policy Works uh in the event a um
a school
um uh that has received building Aid as
part of its its construction or
renovation costs it has that it's been
determined that it's being used for
something else you could just sort of
lead us through how that works how many
times this has happened maybe before and
um and um you know what we can expect
um it has happened I'm familiar with at
least three if not more cases where it's
happened
um the law says that the penalty
um is paid back but there's some
discretion at the commissioner's level
uh at the department of education's
level and what the department did at
that time is that we just prorated so
one of the schools closed at like 18
years and so essentially we just did it
so keep in mind that we used to pay on
the the term of the bond so it was much
easier under that old model to just say
well you're closing we're not going to
pay any more building Aid we don't
actually have to get any money back from
them we just stopped paying them in all
three cases we did that in all three
cases
um they were at the at the very end of
their time and then um of course A lot
of times
um you know your Club Elementary School
in Berlin and just closed I think that
might have been one of them that had you
know had done some small work
um it's diff it would be really
difficult in that situation to be like
oh pay that five million dollars back
right
um so in that case we just stopped
payment and it is a good thought for
this group now thinking about what
happens if we're giving all of that
money up front the 80 up front and 20
upon completion it's definitely a lot
more difficult
um to get money back
so and and a follow-up on that
so
um
so would a
well I guess you know would it would a
would a change of use
include
um
the building being used for a school
district and then maybe the building
being used for some other
um
operating entity as a as a school would
that be a change of of use if there was
a change of ownership
um change of ownership so you know if
you had a school that was then turned
over to the YMCA and now they're
operating it yeah that would not be a
pay for YMCA so that would be a change
of view it would be a change of use yeah
you could have a school you could have a
K-12 school that turns it into an SAU
office and that also would not be that
would also require them to pay it back
because it's for 12 the law says that
it's for K-12 education
um and
um you know so if they turned it into an
SAU office that they would be required
to turn that money back over okay and
and you you'd mentioned that in in your
experience the the few times this has
happened it's been towards the tail end
of a 20-year thing where
um you know a lot of people's crystal
balls don't go out this early 20 years
yeah and um and we can sort of see that
happening but have you seen any any
changes of use or or District failures
uh in the first you know few years you
know you know one two three years after
after a building was was either
constructed or substantially renovated I
have not no
and I do know that sometimes I get calls
from schools saying oh well we were
thinking about changing the space to a
preschool space which is not an eligible
building Aid cost
um and then they find out that that puts
them in Jeopardy of having to pay their
ability Aid back and they're like oh
that's not a good space for preschool
then
um it's really pretty easy for decision
at that point
um you they can request a waiver you
know consideration from the Department
the law does allow that
um
to shifting spaces in something like a
preschool might make sense we always
tell the districts if it makes sense
approach us because you know we want to
make some good decisions for the
district but they are wise to make um
that call because the law does say K-12
education great thank you Amy
yes representative dry and then
represent woodcock
thank you Mr chairman
going back to 194 B 11
we talked about
um there will be no school building
awarded to a chartered public school but
there's that Clause at the end of the
sentence that says unless the building
is owned by the school district under
lease to the chartered public school and
such lease does not include an option to
purchase the building this is different
than a charter conversion school is that
correct
do you want I don't I I don't know the
way I've when I've read that um before
um
um is that I have always been that is
when the school district owns that space
and the charter school is leasing that
space is that also a conversion school
okay this is simply a tennis so for me
that that law has always been confusing
to me because I'm like it wouldn't be
the charter school that would be
applying for it anyway it would be the
school district so they could apply for
those spaces and follow up are there
schools that fit that unless Clause okay
I don't know I don't believe so do you
there there are some charter schools
that at least from uh Public Schools
here I can think of two offhand
and one more follow-up so then they
would be eligible to apply for building
Aid they the charter school or the
district that's a good question like I
read it it sounds like the district but
I'm not an attorney so so
we have always said it would be the
school district that would apply because
the charter schools are eligible for
lease Aid so
um it's
um
maybe it's not that well written but we
have always said it would be the school
district they're leasing from the school
district so this it would be receiving
an application from the school district
not the charter school building owner
it's a building owner
okay thank you
thanks chair a question let's go back to
your dissolution I meant I don't know if
uh child school property uh he said that
the in the doe I think what you said was
in the doe application that process
identified
what the disillusion process is going to
be if they have to dissolve yeah the the
languages they must have a dissolution
plan as part of their Charter
application each plan could be slightly
different
um depending on the organization but
they have to have a plan yes
well thank you so to to that then those
plans public information
I assume they would because they're part
of the charter application in the
charter application is public
information yes thank you and does the
department have copies of that Charter
application
we do okay I'm looking at another
section law 194 B 16.
and a section Romans 7 if the charter if
a school's Charter expires or is revoked
the school shall be dissolved under the
provisions of his Charter application
and contract that the contract
Provisions are silent or ambiguous as to
the disposition of any asset of the
school do you have any uh Charters that
still have that in ambiguous uh language
that may have required this to be
written that would uh cause some issues
in terms of the disposition of assets of
the school
further questions Amy I have one for you
it's jumping off the charter school a
little bit
um when we look at all these 17
applications which we received there's
some that are large and some that are
smaller I know there's some states which
I have several pots of money available
one for
well maybe in one for leasing one for uh
possibly I'll take a figure five million
dollars left less or three million
dollars less and then those for the
larger ones
um
my concern is that when we get to some
of these large projects and they're
going to come at us
we could end up funding just one project
in a period while right now right now in
Period of two years seeing the Tails
taking half of what we appropriate
so
do you know of any states where it may
be working where they have several pots
of money where we can allocate resources
out depending upon the size of the
application
um I'm not sure I know that some have
different pots of money for different
types of projects so like if you were
going to do a
um a window project or a door
replacement project so that makes those
projects smaller you're talking about
renovation yeah renovation but
um keep in mind when for building Aid
you definitely wouldn't want to make a
pot for renovation and a pot for new
because the renovations when we talk
about a renovation we're talking about
open studs and just doing a full
renovation the law defines it as
substantial renovation so you're really
bringing up that space up to new
oftentimes those types of renovation
projects cost just as much sometimes
even more than a new build
um
in
in I I think if you're wanting to reach
more people if if you're doing that to
me that says that you want to reach more
people with the money
um because a lot of these brand new
buildings or new builds are because the
building itself is in really bad
condition
um and so it's not that that isn't where
the money should focus on because those
are like your worst buildings usually
um but if you're in if you're interested
in pushing money out to reach more
people which I can see that would be a
big benefit as well
you may want to consider how we operate
lease Aid well how we operate we say it
is people apply for lease Aid and we
fund everybody on the list and that way
you're not ranking these projects
um
I think that is a good thing for you all
to look at is like those 17 projects
come in we get an appropriation and we
you can still prorate people you can
still grant them an award based on more
affluent less affluent maybe even give
them more more percentage points for the
types of projects that you want to float
to have more
um
more importance and then you could just
prorate everybody across the list that
way everybody is getting a share of
whatever was appropriated
for me that solves a couple of problems
it solves the big problem of of schools
not feeling like they have to rush and
get a big project in they could do
projects in pieces a lot better they
could do phasing of a project a lot
better they can do smaller projects a
lot better and the department wouldn't
be ranking these projects so that it
would allow everybody to compete on a
Level Playing Field
legislatively doesn't give Focus onto
only those that are receiving the aid
that are at the top
um and I feel like if you've got a list
that everybody kind of it's not all
about who's on the list anymore it's
just a matter of those are the people
that are going to get Aid
the problem with that because I have
thought this through the problem with
that is you never know how much you're
going to get
um and you don't know how many people
are going to apply so one year you might
be prorating it 80 everybody gets 80 of
what they the formula shakes out to be
and other years you might be like oh
you're only going to get 30 of whatever
the formula shakes out to be and we say
that happened in Lee said one year we
gave everybody like 44 of what they were
asking for the following year the
legislature bumped that amount up and so
it gives a true a better in my opinion
it gives a better picture of what the
real ask is the real ask is this amount
and schools could still reject that
award like it'd be like oh I can't do it
if the state's only going to give me 30
percent of what I'm asking for
they could just wait and apply later you
know there are I think that could
something I I hope that you consider of
um during this time
and one other question I have I'm trying
to dig down in my memory here and Define
renovation
um I somehow 25 of the cost of
construction rings a bell but I'm not
sure where is that break off between
maintenance and renovation
um I think what you're referring to is
that
um in the law there is a requirement the
definition of substantial renovation is
your project has to be at least a
renovation project of at least five
million dollars or 25 of what it would
cost to build a new building those are
for those those are that law was in
there just for those smaller projects to
say well five million dollars might be a
lot for what the little schools so maybe
they have to meet something smaller so
it's 25 percent of whatever is new
um that would define a substantial
renovation
maintenance we think of Maintenance as
um
prepare for and you can put in your
regular school budget such as window
replacements roof Replacements that
don't aren't big Capital construction
projects they're expensive and building
a used to pay for them but those are
kind of your those are considered like
more your some people call them
renovation because they're replacing
their windows but in our world we'd call
that maintenance
okay I got one last one here
um sorry to everybody else but
um we had a proposal that came forward
and everybody has a copy of that
Amendment
it's a back to the pack that was handed
out
this amendment um
967h
I won't say any names
this amendment
dealt with
another way of
paying for a classroom space
and it'll be an annual commitment of
dollars to these districts we talked
about this in finance
300 for each people in the
municipalities admr in grades
kindergarten through grade eight 350
dollars for each people in the
municipalities admr in grades nine
through twelve
can you comment on that approach of
giving this blanket amount annually
to the schools for them to put into a
fund which is only usable for
if we don't change it for construction
of a new construction renovation
first first what we're doing what are
some shortcomings what are some of the
positives of it
well the big I think the definitely the
positive of it is it targets it just
gives everybody some money
to allocate to what it might cost them
right so
um for somebody who just built something
that's great because they're going to
get they're going to get some extra
money that they probably never think
that they're ever going to see anyway it
just essentially distributes money cost
per pupil to school districts
um
the biggest problem is that I think this
is designed so that you collect a little
bit of money each year per student and
you are responsible and save it which I
in the ideal world I think that that's a
great option
um but if that was in place 50 years ago
and there was some restrictions on it
then 50 years now we would have some
money so unless somebody's willing to
put in
um my estimates is about 10 billion
dollars into a an account so that people
can start getting the savings that they
should have had 50 years ago per pupil
throughout the life of the account then
um I guess that's the shortcoming the
shortcoming is that there's no money
right now for people to do construction
projects and there won't be for 40 years
um the way the law that house bill is
written
um
I'm sure there are good things about it
I'm just gonna say um I'm from
Washington DC and back home we have a
similar program each and this has been a
few years but each Charter School
essentially has a facilities credit per
year per student that used to be in the
1500 to 2 000 range and then
those those credits
um saved up each year actually became
the down payment for many of those
charter schools to purchase buildings
um and then also maintain the existing
facility they were in
um that became a springboard for
building ownership for charter schools
which if you were to look at a charter
school the two biggest expenses they
have are typically lease and salary
many of them can never get out of the
cycle of purchasing a building because
they can't save enough money to buy a
building so those lease credits excuse
me those facilities credits served a
purpose and they allowed charter schools
to accumulate enough money
to acquire a down payment so they could
eventually buy a building so it it works
in other states
and I'd say if you if the if the state
were to move forward with this then it
might run well in tandem with a program
so that it's ready in 40 years to be
used and it doesn't have to be 40 years
I mean people could cash in their
credits I would also use them as credits
so that that money just doesn't kind of
disappear
but you know somebody might want to tap
into it in 20 years for time and use it
at that time
should the we if if we venture down this
road
do you think it's fair to say that all K
through eights are going to get 300
bucks all high schools are going to get
350 bucks or should there be other
criteria that come into the mix
such as property wealth or or isolation
or you know demographic
um
that I think that's 100 a policy
question I mean it's not the Department
of Education really doesn't have a role
in that I I think
um whatever you all decide of where that
money should be distributed
um My Hope Is that I come up you you
come up with a process that will allow
schools to have a functioning and you
know probably even more importantly a
way to plan like what what is there what
can they plan for if it's ten percent
it's ten percent if it's 40 it's 40 but
um and if it's nothing it's nothing but
I think some kind of process
um that schools can
um work with is really important I'm
sure if school is sitting here they
would be like oh zero percent is not
okay
um so maybe I should take that back a
little bit but
um I think it will be really helpful for
right now building Aid is just really
volatile it's like some money no money
maybe some money maybe enough for one
school maybe not for three schools it's
just it's
um a little bit of a roller coaster
because there because that cap is a
maximum cap not a minimum cap and
I don't know sometimes I wonder if there
should even be a cap um I don't know if
it hinders or at all but
versus changing it to a minimum or a
maximum I don't know it it's uh I don't
know that money thing is hard because
money's hard to
to dedicate so
yes yes yeah just just one years in
lines
been provided capacity to access to
resources
could you say again what what that
um
again this and this would have been a
decade or more ago but it was somewhere
between fifteen hundred and two thousand
dollars on facilities I don't know if
they've changed it or if it had
graduating amounts we just we had a
building of 50 000 square feet and I
remember that number as our set
basis and is there a way that we we can
get maybe a
you know a summary of If that program
I could reach out to my counterparts in
on a harder basis on a public school
going back to Washington DC
um in Kentucky they're required they've
sort of a similar program but they also
have what they cost First first nickel
and that means that the district has to
put some money in the kitty before
they're going to collect their credits
so there's sort of kind of some
ownership in this uh would anything like
that be existing in Washington where you
came from or not that I'm aware of um
but I I'll actually do a little bit of
digging both in Washington DC but also
reach out to the National Charter School
resource center and see what other
states are doing with this specific
issue thank you Rick on on that very
um issue I think that's very interesting
because you know that's uh it's getting
us out of the first and last dollar into
glasses
to get to the rest of the way yeah and
maybe that's a model for um for building
Jen can you do some research with us
please and get us all that information
you gave me you funneled some
information about Kentucky to me can you
hit all those links and trying
thank you and with the education
Commission in the states I think that's
where you got it
yeah
any further need from the Department
I know it Amy uh you have
um I know you have thoughts on
on the lease program and some of these
other Ventures as far as funding
building Aid
um do you think you could put some of
that together for us
you know in in uh because we want to
look at this thing seriously and figure
out how we can support both their
Charters and how we can support the
public schools that are needing this Aid
with the limited dollar we have is still
you know
we will be losing this tail here shortly
in about another five years or so a good
part of the table so that means there's
going to be a lot more than just 50
million dollars available per year maybe
as much as 75 80 million dollars
so that's that's something to look
forward but I'm happy to do that thank
further questions
thank you very much for coming today
thank you
is there any more discussion from the
committee on this we'll we'll get some
of this research in and what we hope to
do is come back in the fall we're we're
not going to be my meeting during the
months of July and August
but we will come back and school billing
Aid will be a topic which we address in
September
so we'll meet then at the call of the
chair
yeah
anything else for today
30. it really it gives down that's my
you can be done with
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I won't keep you very long I
know you are sort of heading out the
door there and that stopped the last
minute my name is Bob best I'm an
attorney at Sullivan Hollis and I'm on
the board of a couple of charter schools
and also on the board of a New Hampshire
Charter School Foundation which is sort
of intended to be a organization that
brings together some of the knowledge
base that different charter schools have
gained over the years to help some of
the newer younger charter schools get
their feet under them very well and I
just like to offer up whatever answers
or discussion that can be had on behalf
of charter schools to some of the
questions that you that you had about
how the building works or how what
happens if a charter school fails and
then it's building and that sort of
thing some of those things are outlined
already in statute pretty well and we
just point out where they are for you
um I think the discussion earlier today
seems to suggest that there's a lot
going on with building Aid and it's not
just about including Charter Schools it
seems like there's lots of moving pieces
and I hope that however that progresses
that Charter Schools just remain sort of
part of that discussion and involved in
whatever that solution is so that we
could have the opportunity to
participate in that in that eight going
forward
um that said I know there's a lot of
questions about how many schools on
their buildings and why and what that
history might have been and what happens
to buildings when charter schools go up
or down
um didn't have to be a discussion today
I know that you guys have had kind of a
full discussion already but in the
future when you come back in the fall
we'll certainly come visit again and be
available to you or you could reach out
to me or to the New Hampshire Charter
School foundation and we could Supply
any written information you'd want in
the interim and we'd be a resource for
you do you have a business card you can
share with the committee oh let's see
I do I mean it's my business from the
law firm it's not from the foundations
or the charter schools but I can get a
phone number on the right you get you
got it it does great
about schools that have not succeeded
sure
[Music]
I I don't have anything like that
prepared but I'd be happy to work with
towel on that I think he's got a lot of
the resources and we'd certainly help
um pull the charter schools to find out
what they've been doing and how they've
been doing with things
um I haven't fortunately knocked on
what's been involved in any of the
schools that have not succeeded so I
don't know what the what the
circumstances were that led them to that
I know that historically the statute in
New Hampshire that um that authorizes
Charter Schools originally didn't allow
any debt uh from by the charter schools
and then that was amended but in the
beginning that's why most Charter
Schools don't own their buildings
because they weren't allowed to have any
death and then when that was changed
then you can have debt and borrow and
buy buildings but the uh the lease Aid
was a strong motivator to stay in the
rental market and so a lot of charter
schools did that and that's why I think
the number I was surprised that that
tell said it was seven I thought it was
more like two or three that owned their
buildings
it's growing because it's becoming more
viable but for a long time the playing
field was tilted towards renting and
that's why there's so many that rent
sure thank you very much anything else
it's b-e-s-d that's right okay thank you
very much Mr best uh and we what we're
going to do is we're going to break till
September but in the interim we're going
to be doing research so we may be giving
you a jingle you don't mind absolutely
anytime thank you
the same for towel I mean Amy
thank you all very much is there
anything else for the committee today
yes
comment about my availability in
September is like Zero To None
um that I can meet on subcommittees
after the Rand trial is done with the
second week of October so if you want to
consider that okay thank you yeah
and if if you are unable you might want
to contact Mel and let him know and you
can have a substitute come into our
committee for you when you can't attend
yep well thank you very much everybody
foreign